perspective hindsight is so when usually
or when I typically think about the
future I'll also say okay I really want
this meeting or this okay right now
we're I'm editorial page editor of the
Boston Globe and we're doing our
endorsements of presidential candidates
so we've been interviewing the
presidential candidates and we're gonna
come out with it
endorsement soon and so I'm thinking oh
I really want this to go well like I
want people to read it I want the
endorsement you really really while I
want to look like this on the page and
this online and I'm thinking I'm
fixating on all these things that I want
to go well in the future and I should
probably use prospective hindsight so
prospective hindsight is a technique
that allows you to sort of get past
thinking about all the factors that you
can't control in the present and
focusing you and distilling sort of what
are the factors what are the decisions
you have that affects future scenarios
so what you would do is you imagine an
outcome as if it's already happened and
so you could do this with like a dinner
party for example or I could do it with
the endorsement page on the you know in
the globe and say okay imagine it's gone
really really well like you just had the
best dinner party and then walk back and
ask yourself why it happened and how it
happened and make a list of those
reasons why was it so great what the
conversation was really good people
really hit it off like there was a lot
of interesting people there the food was
delicious it's probably not factors like
you know maybe the weather made it made
a little bit of a difference but it's
probably not factors like that it
probably doesn't matter whether you
serve dessert right away or if you
waited right so all these sort of things
that we can fixate on about the future
get kind of stripped away when you ask
the how and the why and that's just a
technique you can use you can also
imagine a scenario going very very wrong
and then walk yourself back from that
and this Deborah Mitchell who was a
Wharton professor came up with this term
perspective hindsight for this and she
actually thought it would have worked
really well to avoid the Chernobyl
disaster if if this technique had been
used but in fact in our lives we can use
something like this